hi guys so i'm back again playing the
walking dead a lot of you seem to really
enjoy it and you want me to carry on
which is great because i'm going to
carry on anyway so i'll just carry on
with you guys
i don't know what that was
excited growl
then she was bitten by a dog
what and you just believed her you
should have put her out of her
oh my god
keep your finger off the trigger boy
whoa whoa what the [ __ ] idiot every
lurker for five miles probably you're
the one telling me to [ __ ] shoot her
everybody just calm down for a second
clementine you okay
i just need a doctor
and then and then i'll go
i don't want my arm to get infected none
of us want to get infected that's the
point we got a doctor right here okay
he'll have a look you know what the hell
is wrong with you people he's being nice
she's just scared we're all scared
don't act like we're the ones being
irrational because we don't buy this
[ __ ] story no way she survived out
here on her own why
let me take a look
it's okay go ahead he's a doctor do it
damn that must have hurt
hmm whatever it was it got you good
yeah
this isn't how we do things man when
you're bit you get put down
end of story i'm not going through this
i don't know
we could take her arm off
i know that worked for a cousin down in
ainsworth we could try that
it won't do any good you'll just be
making it worse for the girl it's crazy
no one's going to volunteer to do that i
would
be saving their life
then
how would we know it worked this guy
just let carlos have a look first
you want to be sure right
you don't want to do something you're
going to regret
i'm on your side kid no need for a guilt
trip
oh
okay
sarah what i say stay inside
that one
i don't mean to be any trouble
i just want to stop the bleeding and
then i'll go
you'll never see me again i promise
and where exactly would you go
um
uh to find a friend find my friend
forget it
you won't get five feet
look i may be in the minority here but
my gut tells me she's telling the truth
it probably is just a dog bite
but like a second ago you were all like
i'm not even touching you if you've been
bit
fine whatever
so what do you think was it a lurker
a bite like that could be anything
only one way to find out how
we wait what
by tomorrow morning if the fever set in
we'll know if she's gonna turn
in the meantime we can lock her in the
shed
that sounds homely
what about my arm it needs to get
cleaned and stitched and bandaged
the girl is in bad shape carlos
we have all that stuff inside the
cabinet we could probably get bobby
we can't do nothing
i'm not wasting supplies on a lurker
bite if it turns out you're telling the
truth i'll clean it stitch it up for you
in the morning but
i'm sorry
it's the best we're gonna get
finger off the trigger son i ain't your
son don't be like that man
it's all right i've always got his mom's
temper this group just seems hostile
this is just a waste of time you'll see
and when she turns i ain't going to be
the one cleaning up the [ __ ]
um
it was a dog you'll see i guess we'll
find out in the morning
if i last that long
maybe you could go look for it
i wish i could i really do but it's too
risky sorry
ugh
how could you not trust that face though
she's not a liar
why are we doing this
it's [ __ ] dumb
because it's safer this way and i'd
rather be sure
i can't believe this
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine
um right what have we got here look in
the toolbox
oh
not much left in here
i guess if i have to i can use this for
stitches
jesus
what's this
i don't even know what that is what is
that
the barrel
wood
nothing
nada
there was something over here
my grandad used to have one of those
all the weapons are gone
okay
all right let's look at this i saw this
oh use the pen knife
oh she needs something to take out
screws
what have we got what have we got
oh
okay
what's this
oh okay and now
hop on that
you get that
she's a really good voice actor
there we go
oh that just for a hammer we got it it's
cool
right i'm gonna use the hammer
okay
i thought she was gonna like undo the
nails
awesome
got a little escape hole
let's keep it home
that became
very fast gotta have stuff for stitches
let's be quiet
okay
right
how do i get into the cabin
let's have a look
look at the windows
come on
probably don't want to use the front
door do i
no
oh knock on the window really okay
who is it
it makes me feel like a [ __ ] idiot
when we're not on the same page we are
on the same page not out there we
weren't not about the girl
i thought you get soft
what do you want me to do back put a
bullet in there i want you to think
about our family first it's all i think
about
so don't give me any [ __ ]
i need for me
he's just a nice guy
she's just an evil lady
what the hell are you doing
um
i'm not going to hurt anyone yeah audrey
island
please i need to fix my arm are you out
of your mind even if you ain't bitten by
some lurker which you probably are you
can't be here you gotta get out of here
you understand get back into that [ __ ]
and call us and take care
guilt trip i can tell that you're nice
i ain't nice
yes you are don't you do that i see what
you're doing don't you do that i'm sorry
daddy i saw when everyone was arguing
you wanted to help
you didn't see anything
look you gotta get out of here before my
wife find you
i'm serious you gotta go
i got enough problems already
we got a baby on the way rebecca's all
emotional got a mess of hormones causing
all sorts of trouble
woman in that woman's trouble i'm
already in trouble just talking to you
uh
i could really use your help i feel bad
now i'm screwed if anyone finds out i
did this you understand
what do you need
the
cut on my arm needs to be cleaned and
stitched stitch i ain't doing that
i'll figure it out on my own all right
look
at
that
we're showing bandages but i might be
able to find something clean that will
work i need something to clean it out
with and a needle and thread could help
too i don't even know where to look
carlos has medical supplies on lockdown
we don't got much these days well
whatever you can get i'll find the rest
on my own okay wait here
ah thank you
yay
oh they're pretty ones
i got you a juice box in case you're
thirsty
so cute
thank you
alvin house meeting in five minutes
oh okay thanks now you need to go
i will i will
oh he's so cute
get me a juice box
okay
i want a juice box i wish someone would
give me a juice box
i need a needle
i probably don't want to use this door
do i
yeah
how does no one feel sorry for her like
seriously she's hobbling around
and everyone's just like yeah screw you
or just leave you to die in the shed
it's nice
okay we found something
ah the hammer you got hammer don't
forget
each one individually
oh my god
this cool place
make it then like a party dead nerd
um
she could still stop things with it
couldn't she's tiny but
well luke has more to say i guess
where's sarah he's got her book she
doesn't need to be a part of it
sneaky wait do i need to open this door
already aren't people in here
oh okay they're in another room okay
it's nice and cozy
what's in that room oh right there
there's no way she's out here by herself
she said she was with a friend oh my god
yeah right
whoever she is i'm not gonna do that for
long because i'm scared they're gonna
find me okay
oh let's just go back
what else is around here
so isn't that where i came
yeah that's where i came
the stairs right okay let's go upstairs
here's where did they start right
oh she's so scared
i would be i'd be freaking out
i'm pretty crap at sneaking although i
am sure so that helps
hiding and stuff
right
what do we have here
see if we can find something in here
right
oh creepy
what's that oh yes a needle
it's clean
i'll still need something to keep it
from getting infected yeah
it's an alcohol
don't panic
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] get in wait go go
i'm always scared that things are behind
the shower kittens
damn it
just need to have this baby
let it be okay and let it be his
oh
now we get why she's so stressed
she'd be cheating she'd be cheating
that's not cool
now i have some juicy gossip
that i can use against her
if needs be because clementine's not
really that nasty
you're not supposed to be in here
um
can you help me
hi can you please help me
i'm not supposed to talk to you
my dad can't know
uh
what are you reading
a book what book i like books
it's called the gurgaon
it's about trans-dimensional body
snatchers ooh
cool
what happened to you
a dog bit me it sounds scary
i bet it hurts
yeah
no don't ask yourself yeah take care
do you understand
i just need something to clean it with i
bet it would be with the rest of your
medical supplies yeah it is
i'll help you good
thank you
i'm sarah
i'm a clementine
i'm clementine
we're friends
right we can be best friends best
friends
way before
it's hard to be the only girl you know
rebecca's okay but she's old yeah fine
yes we're friends yes
we are friends promise it's important oh
my god friends have to trust each other
no matter what do you promise uh
i said yes i said yes
oh god
why are you doing this to me
fine yes
yes
give me my pinky
a pinky swears forever
so nice i'll see if i can find the stuff
my dad uses when i get a cut
let me look around
i think this is it
that'll work you can't do it here though
someone will find you don't worry i
won't
okay thanks sarah
so is that everything i got the thread
back in the shed
i better get some wrapping and then
yeah cool so i'm done
snickers [ __ ]
what's around here
another door
anything of use in here is this just a
useless bedroom
what's this
board game
play it with your new best friend hey
i think this is just a useless room a
minute
wait why am i taking
that don't take it put it back
oh god no why did i do that
it's about have it no put it back
oh no i want to start over put it back
i'm gonna have to start over i'm so
sorry
i'm not taking
okay so
i just redid that all again so that i
didn't take the watch because i'm so
stupid but i would never do that i just
kind of clicked it
just out of habit i suppose but i know
clementine wouldn't take the watch
and i wouldn't take the watch
so we aren't gonna take the what
and how do we get back oh yeah this way
so we've got the stuff down and we're
gonna patch ourselves up
i don't think i could do that
um
okay
at least she's got pretty
like wrapping whatever that is
juice
where'd she put all that stuff she just
hold it
okay here we go
this is gonna suck
uh that one first isn't it
disinfect it
okay
okay
okay i'm good
i'm fine good
now the fun part
have some juice first make you feel
better
oh god do i have to do everything okay
thread it through
and now
just like last time
just how crystal showed me okay
oh really
oh god
i'm pretty screamish with this kind of
stuff
the voice acting is so good
okay
come on how many more not many more
whoa
it just looks so fleshy and like the
noises
okay
i think this will be the last one or
second to last
oh
the noises
the zombies are gonna hit you oh no
just realized okay last one
oh god
okay
now just to wrap it up and drink the
rest of your juice
and this will be good
okay uh oh there's nothing there
oh yeah there was there was a rake right
get the bike over this way
oh god i suck at this
uh
what's this
okay bash him in the head yes
what's this bash him in the head again
another one
in the head again
uh kiki
you did it
holy [ __ ] what you see you see why you
left her out here she was gonna die i
didn't get in here little girls tough as
nails are you all right
i'm still safe
i'm still
not
bitten
i never was
and you left me out here to die
you patched yourself up where'd you get
that stuff she steal from us
this doesn't change a thing she hasn't
done anything to us
you left me no choice you could have
just left true
relax rebecca
bring her in and i'll take a look at her
arm thank you damn look at sneaking
around out here we better get inside
you hungry
oh the cold shoulder
it okay i'm gonna leave it there for now
i hope you enjoyed that and i will be
carrying on again very soon have a
lovely day or evening bye oh god what do
i do what do i do what do i do
oh my god oh my god
i died
because i was freaking out